[Music]
it's July 20th 1969 across the country
an estimated 615 million Americans have
tuned in to watch the first men land on
the moon also watching is Joe Thompson
you don't know her name yet but without
Joe and her sister seamstresses those
men would have never made it to the moon
and back again my name is Joe Thompson
and back in the 60s
I sewed on spacesuits for Neil Armstrong
Buzz Aldrin and Michael Collins and we
would bury the thread like that and see
now it's tucked under when I was about
six or seven that's when my aunt taught
me about sewing so that I was able to
make a pretty decent doll dress I am
proud I was a seamstress and I'm glad
that what we did was a great success but
the seamstresses really have gone
undocumented right there that's me
without our attention to detail and our
dedication they would not have been able
to do what they did
in 1966 Joe was recruited onto an elite
team of seamstresses by former bra
Factory ILC Dover in the years to come
she'd help create some of the most
complicated technology of the 20th
century there were layers of insulation
the cemented area that held the air when
they invaded it that was the inner layer
then there was an outer layer inside
even all of that he had like a spandex
suit that had tubes running in through
it then there was a neck ring that the
helmet attached to it was quite a
engineering marvel my job required me to
do things that were technical and
challenging when we cut the items out it
had to be placed back on a pattern to be
accepted and it was not more than a 64th
of an inch the tolerance of a 64th of an
inch is very small it's some probably
not much more than a hairbreadth if you
made a needle hole by stitching wrong
somewhere when the suit was under
pressure then the suit would leak if his
suit started leaking air there's only
one thing could happen and that would be
you wouldn't make it back home
[Music]
50 years ago is a long time I think it
was fairly early in the evening it was
when he got out and stepped on the moon
that I really felt like this is the
final test of what we did I had a small
black and white TV with not a whole lot
of good reception I suppose there was
more people there but to me I was the
only one there and I was the only one
that was responsible for this man being
on the moon holding my breath to make
sure he made it back again every time I
see the moon it reminds me of all the
people I worked with and what we be made
and I look up there and I think a man
was actually on that moon and he
actually wore something that I had my
hand on can't believe it
[Applause]